sadly his brother didn't make it but I
don't know what to do with this little
guy
he won't leave his brother
I wouldn't leave my brother in the
trenches so
so I picked up the Gosling took her to
uh the side of the road and then when it
was clear again I went to go get the
second one ran back to the truck and uh
put the Gosling in the truck I guess
we'll drop him off by a pond
he's having some Timmy's coffee everyone
was like no no he can't do that it'll
die and uh you gotta take it to a
wildlife sanctuary and I'm on my way to
a job site so oh Fowler likes me
chilling on my lap I'm passing through
Martinsville and uh this cop is coming
the other way and I'm kind of the
Gosling jumped on my lap he was kind of
chirping at me the whole time
update here
I think the cops might take him
so we got the police to save the duck
here
honestly it was kind of just Instinct I
mean I would I don't like I like saving
animals uh sometimes little gestures can
make big impacts so
and posting on my Snapchat story maybe I
could Inspire others to save animals and
yeah
what do you do with the brother